well hi priyanka my name is bryce what's
my name
hi bryce my name is priyanka what's my
name priyanka
that's right the first ever canadian
drag
superstar coming at you from toronto and
you feel
you know real low energy about it a very
calm cool collective
i did can you believe it i am so excited
for you
i you were my favorite all season long i
was alive
i was telling the people before i got on
the call i said i wasn't sure if i was
going to have
questions for rita or scarlett if they
want
so i'm very happy to talk to you i want
to start with the name thing because
that's the thing
you're shady and i like it we're gonna
be friends by the end of this
uh i want to start with the name thing
because that's a thing you've done
for forever if you scroll back in your
social media you've coerced
thousands of rue girls at this point
into saying your name
yeah my name is priyanka what's my name
her name is priyanka
oh if you want me to say hi name that
cameo say my name
my name is priyanka what's my name no
what's my name
what where'd you get this idea to do
that okay it was my drag mother's idea
access the love
she was like listen everybody on church
thinks that you're tinomi banks so if
you could please
start saying your name more often that
would be great thank you and then i just
took it and i
ran with it and then i was like what's
my name what's my name
say my name all the time say my name say
my name
all the time every day everyone's like
we get it we get it we get it
well now everyone in the world or at
least select parts of north america
knows your name it's wild there's people
from
every country like just being the most
amazing and so excited about priyanka
winning canada's dragons
it's messed up man all in a paper dress
[Laughter]
it's not messed up it's a big deal you
are the very first
canadian drag superstar you know what i
just love the idea that like
in a year from now everyone's gonna be
like yeah priyanka was the first ever
winner and that's just normal that's
just in the history books
i think it's so cool because i want like
other like south asian people west
indian people to look at me
as a person of color and be like if that
little scrawny brown boy can do it so
can i uh on the finale
you talked about how your dad didn't
know you were gay didn't know you did
drag
in june you shared the coming out story
on twitter what was dad's reaction last
night when
when you got crowned our queen
thank you i'm living proof that hard
work pays off
and that even when you make mistakes you
could still be a winner
what's my name
he said give me the check
he's so proud of me it's so cool he's
he's up and down
with this whole drag thing like he's
like supporting it because he
understands that drag race is a big deal
but then his demons in his brain from
his upbringing
tells him that boys can't dress up as
girls
so i think that he's trying his hardest
to support me
and then sometimes the upbringing comes
and he's like no it's wrong he's like
fight them off so
i'm giving him time to process it but at
the end of the day he's proud of his
little boy
he loves you and i know your mom loves
you she was there at your party last
night i saw the pictures
my mom is the one let me tell you
something about my mom so
yes we could talk about the amazing
mother she is and the support but i want
you
to know how she read my looks this
season
i wore the black latex look episode 2
and she was like what was that garbage
bag you were wearing
after i bombed the improv challenge and
the second time i was in the bottom she
calls me and says
what were you thinking i paid for all
that tv school and that's what you did
i was like oh sorry mom wow mom yonka
giving uh jeffrey boyer chapman a run
for his mother
i'm not bad
uh we'll circle back to that in a second
but i want to talk more about your
journey
on the show you were the narrator of
this season and i always love when the
narrator
takes the win home nobody is safe
which is very exciting cause anything
can happen
did you know you were gonna be the
narrator did you have any inkling that
like my interviews are so good they're
going to use
every single bite i give them my
interviews are so good i'm so good at
everything oh my goodness
i had no clue at all it wasn't until the
fans started kind of like placing me
as you know the narrator of the season
and this
of the season because they're all trying
to figure it out everyone's always
trying to crack the code to drag race
so like okay so if you take creon could
make her the narrator
and then we take this person you know i
i loved it i was just having fun in
those interviews i was just so happy
to finally be able to be myself and like
be priyanka out of drag on camera
while competing to be the first ever
canadian drug superstar you know like
that's why that's where all that
happiness came from and me like just
like
getting my life and saying go out jimbo
get in jimbo or take jimbo down do you
copy
all of that was just me just trying to
be my myself
well it was great and you had plenty of
yourself moments on the main stage two
and the work room
uh your lip syncs two of the most iconic
in
drag race herstory not just canadian
drag race herstory but drag race
the whole global phenomenon that this
show is i mean
i was torn between starting the
interview with what i did or just going
doing a bacon hello or the pageant
or the pageant
if you had to pick one song to lip-sync
for the rest of your career
hello or i drove all night what is it i
drove all night
my favorite part of the entire lip sync
is when
i said i'm not going home
and i jumped into the split
on the bridge of the song and said the
taste of squeakiest is your answer
why is burning like who do you think you
are miss thing
i watch that lipstick i can't believe
i'm watching myself it's wild
and you're poor poom poom my
i got so litty i split my kitty
cause when your puss has a crash we'll
get you again
knowing what you know now how everything
played out would you do anything
differently would you go back and start
it all over would you do it again
you know what i would do it all over
again just for fun
just for funsies um but i wouldn't
change anything i'm so happy i bombed
snatch game we got i drove all night
although mentally it was a hard time
being in the bottom the second time it
caused a lot of
turmoil in my life i'm happy it happened
because then we got hello
i think that like my journey is so cool
because there's never been a drag race
winner that's been in the bottom
twice and to prove that you can really
rise up and get your redemption
and get your crown is incredible i
wouldn't
change anything maybe a runway i would
really want to like
vamp up my denim on denim look that's
the only look i'm like
forgettable so no regrets no apologies
to make
roo apologies i would like to
apologize to kyne for calling you the
villain of the season
i'm sorry i'm just trying to be nice
today just today just this one day
tomorrow we can throw it all out all
right i honestly client actually texted
me something beautiful and she's like
very very proud of me and she's such a
nice person i love her
am i just saying that i'm all just
saying that she's nice you don't believe
me
next question no i trust you i trust you
okay i have some
some burning cues about the season why
did you guys use messy makeup
wipes to clean the mirror instead of
something that would actually clean the
mirror
we like a challenge this is drag race
bryce
stop it why are you trying to make it
easy on us huh so you this is the you
have a
the mini challenge the main challenge
and then this is the sad after challenge
like yeah it's like the aft challenge
all right this is a question on behalf
of trixie mattel
who i don't know if you've been watching
her pit stops
i have been she's she's not okay with
the lack of padding and boobs on canada
what's going on why aren't we padded for
the gods
our boobs today because canada's drag is
so
diverse so we have a lot of queens that
don't wear pads or don't wear boobs or
it doesn't really matter so to be kind
of like put in a little bit
of like a box of saying like you have to
wear boobs
it's kind of like old news i love trixie
so much i do
but the other thing i will say about
boobs and padding is it's all about
silhouette so if you're not going to
wear pads
maybe at least push like wear a corset
on on your stomach sometimes you get a
shave because
it's not fun looking at like a hot dog
walk down the run
you know it's like oh cool great wow
all right we're circling back to jeffrey
he's got a lot of hate
he got a lot of hate online i i think
the hate wasn't
so deserved i think he was doing his job
he was giving critiques
what do you make of it i think that you
should mind your own business
this interview is over what i'm getting
i i
my actual takeaway from that is i feel
like the audience didn't trust the
judges going into episode
one so because they don't know them as
judges there's no rapport built so
they're kind of looking at them like
what do they know you know
but we as the contestants we went into
this competition
knowing that they're gonna be there so
we want we wanted to impress them so
whatever they said goes whenever a fan
loves a drag race girl something happens
to them where they
over love it's like me in a relationship
stage five klinger
and these fans forget that
you know just because you support
someone doesn't mean you have to hate on
someone else
and what's weird is that they kind of
started treating jeffrey like a drag
race girl it was like it was like
us against jeffrey so whenever he would
say something mean to us it's like let's
make jeffrey look bad
to to to to make jimbo look better
that's unfair
he's very like get her jade all right my
last question
can we retire the word [ __ ] now
let's do a seance for [ __ ] [ __ ]
you are done you are over it was the
most annoying thing to come out of
canada's drag race and we are happy here
on entertainment tonight to say goodbye
to it goodbye
[ __ ] r.i.p [ __ ] 2020 to 2020.
we did it there we go well
congratulations i am so excited to see
what you're able to do
and i can't wait to see more of priyanka
yeah what's my name
priyanka that's right don't worry